um so you have your favorite problem of
interest and you want to understand is
it solvable or not and what determines
that well there's some systematic ways
of thinking about that and uh very
excited to have bos bach from harvard
tell us a little bit about
how one might think about these things
thank you thank you very much
and i have to say i'm personally very
excited to give my first
in-person talk since
february of 2020
and
i just i came over invited today from a
six hour flight from boston so i'm
giving you the full multimedia
experience you can see me hear me and
even smell me so
that's something you cannot do for zoom
so
so i'm going to give a very a kind of
high level talk about
some of the ideas and i'm not going to
be able to cover
uh all of the
different frameworks we have for
distinguishing between easy the nest and
hardness and even the ones that i am
able to talk to i'm not going to be able
to go into detail but i hope
to give some kind of an overview that
would be
fleshed out
throughout this workshop and and for
this semester
so maybe the
to starting point is some
puzzle or paradox if you will
of the different intuitions the
different people that engage with
computational problems have about
what the world looks like
so
um complexity theorists typically say er
everything doesn't like to say that
that you know p equals np means
creativity can be automated and we can
believe that p is different from np and
creativity maybe can't be automated
because so complexity theorists also say
that p is different from np
which means that problems are generally
hard generally we
if we're talking about some optimization
problems
we don't have a general way to solve all
of them
cryptographers have this very um
strong intuition
that in some sense an average case
problem is hard and less proven
otherwise
so the default uh the default state of a
computational problems is that they are
hard so for example they
in some sense the intuition behind the
constructions of block ciphers
is that if you just combine together
some operations
unless you're being really stupid as a
block cipher designer you'll get
something that is actually secure
so you basically just need to ensure
some what they call diffusion or
non-locality and some non-linearity and
you just repeat it for a few rounds and
you'll get something that is secure so
basically
the hardness is the norm not the
exception
and similarly this is kind of the
intuition also be behind the learning
with errors problem so it basically says
take the most basic problem that we all
you know learned
you know that our kids would have
learned if it wasn't a zoom school and
solving linear equations
and you just throw out you know two
things to rule out the most obvious
algorithms
so um
you add some noise to kill gaussian
elimination and you make things discrete
to kill least square minimization and it
becomes hard
and and generally that's how you know
cryptographers manufactures assumptions
on a weekly basis and the general
intuition is that uh you know you uh
you come up with this assumption you
just test out the obvious algorithm if
it doesn't work this probably is a valid
assumption it's probably secure and it's
probably hard to solve it and
more often than not they actually seem
to be to work out like sometimes it
doesn't but more often than not it does
work out
and this is a very these kind of
intuitions are very very um
seem to be very very incompatible with
the intuition let's say
of applied machine learning folks so
you've never seen i think an applied
machine learning for a person that says
oh no my objective is non-convex let me
not even try to run it it's definitely
not going to work out let me try to look
for something else because there is no
way when gradient descent gets something
good when i have a non-convex
objective no they solve
you know non-convex objectives every day
every day of the week and it never seems
to stop them and never seems to bother
them at all
and in fact they also have the intuition
the in some sense that the creativity
can be automated this is the whole kind
of idea of ai right
creativity can be automated so so we
have these kind of
different perspectives on computation
and maybe on creativity and i'd like to
try to say how can we
reconcile them in particular let's look
at the two extreme views so
maybe the machine learning view
is that problems are easy except maybe
few pathological cases which might not
be that interesting in practice so there
is like a sea of easiness and maybe a
few islands of
difficulty
and the crypto view is that
problems are hard except for a few
pathological cases where somehow the
stars align and the algorithms actually
work so there is a sea of hardness
and and
and maybe a few islands of easiness
and but both agree in some sense that in
in both regimes
both machine learning uh people
especially applied ones and
cryptographers
agreed that
the algorithms that you use are sort of
the obvious ones
you know they
it's not as if machine learning
people think the problems are easy
because they really think strong and
hard about which algorithm to apply to
particular problems no you just find
some kind of a gradient based algorithm
it will work out and similar
cryptographers
they look at the
three four candidate algorithms they
rule them out and they continue on with
their day they based you know
they now use that uh assumption to
secure
the nuclear warheads and and get on with
their lives hopefully also they get on
with our lives
with this security assumption
so so in some sense both of them kind of
agree
that t is different from np there isn't
some
unknown
algorithm waiting to be discovered by
someone that will you know solve uh or
problems in the worst case
and in some sense they also agree it
sucks that creativity can be automated
at least creativity and algorithm design
there isn't um there isn't this vast
space of algorithms to be
that you need some creative genius to
discover
there is a you know collection of
a handful of algorithms that you should
try out and if you can try out if this
works for your problem then the problem
is easy if it's not it's out then the
only disagreement is how many of them
are easy and how many of them are hard
so in some sense the way to reconcile it
is to say that basically these
these people are just looking at
different regimes there is a space of
problems and there is some side of the
space where
most
instances are hard and some side of this
space where most instances are easy
and
cryptographers by their very nature they
are interested in this
regime
where things are more more hard they
have nothing to look for here and if
they find themselves here they
immediately change some parameter
so they become so they find themselves
in this
in this regime and if you're doing
machine learning you're interested in
this
in this area and if by accident you find
yourself in this area
well you just
increase ask for more data and increase
the size of your model until you find
yourself back in this area
so in some sense that's maybe the
intuition how you could reconcile them
but
this is kind of a very uh hand-wavy or
philosophical and probably not
universally agreed upon but let's
try to look at for
and but we'll we'll try to talk about
when our specific instances where things
can be a little bit more uh
formal
so what does it mean the obvious
algorithm so usually we don't have
really one obvious algorithm but we have
some collection of natural algorithms
for
optimization problems and for sampling
problems and we have this kind of
general phenomena
so in many many problems there is some
kind of a threshold
where
beyond this threshold all known
algorithms fail
and below this pressure many of these
algorithms work they not always reach
this so if you have like this collection
of natural algorithms
maybe some of them will be a little bit
sub optimal some of them might be uh
you know so there would be typically
there would be at least a few of them
that actually reach the threshold but
maybe some that are not that optimal and
fail somehow below the threshold but it
does seem that this threshold beyond it
nothing can work and there is some
algorithm from this natural collection
that matches it that seems to be a
recurring phenomena
and
we'll talk a little bit about some
instances of this in this talk and i
think we'll see many more
in this weekend
in this semester
so
any kind of questions etc about the this
general outline let's use the fact that
yes yes david
the idea that p not equal to np is not
an impediment to the algorithm that's uh
in practice has been a even before
machine learning revolution
lots of practitioners run algorithms
from
real life problems like integer
programming problems
and has been very successful so this
idea that uh
that p naught equal to np is not in
parallel to practical that is pretty old
right so this is not just ml right this
is i could have used i use the ml just
to be concrete and i use cryptographers
you know as an example to be complete
but but generally uh you know people
doing uh
you know industrial optimization
they also have the same kind of view
and i think it's also for a similar
reason i mean
if they find themselves with an input
that's here
they find some way to translate it here
and uh so if they find themselves with a
problem that is hard typically they have
some freedom in modeling the problem or
again they could be gathering more data
in
introducing more assumptions doing
something to the problem
uh
until they
so they have so
so in another way to think about it is
uh the following thing
that our standard paradigm the way we
teach it in a undergrad class
is typically
the there is first a problem
the problem is given to you by god
or by the instructor that gave you your
exam or problem set
and you have to think hard
and find an algorithm right that's the
uh
i don't know cs data structures one uh
paradigm
so there is the problem is fixed
and you have to uh
now you have to think creatively figure
an algorithm for this problem and the
way maybe it works in practice is that
you have your algorithm
and you have your problem
and now you have to massage it into
problem prime
until you can use the same algorithm
because the algorithm is not going to
change it's always going to be the same
algorithm like if you're doing an
optimization you're basically going to
use the same kind of solver the only
question is how do you
change the problem i gather more data to
do something until it it can be used for
this algorithm
and yeah there is some evidence which
are always a lot for a work for of
people in this room and which will
mention
that this kind of threshold is inherent
that there really is in many many
question
cases you have a problems that are
parameterized by some parameter
and there is a certain threshold when
the parameter is say above the threshold
the problem is hard when it's below the
problem is easy or as we'll say that
it's more like ranges of threshold than
the the nature of the problem also
changes
as we'll see that
so what we'll talk about this
so we'll we'll talk about inference
we'll talk about optimization and in
particular for the viewpoint of a
constrained satisfaction problems and
particular type of constraints as the
reaction problem
and
we'll talk about different tasks that
you can do
with these computation problems
including search sampling counting
decision refutation and planted recovery
and as you see by this long list and
it's going to be get longer we are only
going to cover
kind of sample from this list
and we'll
mention
although we not talk so much about many
of those will mention different
algorithms or models that have been used
to either solve these problems or to
give evidence that they cannot be solved
and these include belief propagation
approximate message passing local
algorithms
monte carlo markov chains
low degree polynomials
sum of squares and other hierarchies of
convex programs
and a statistical query model
and i'll briefly mention because you
know the machine learning is obviously
practical machine learning is
obviously a
big deal in practice today and while
it's not the focus of this workshop i'll
try to mention of how these things like
say inference relate to what people do
with respect to machine learning in
practice
and at least touch on it
and
one of this threshold thing
this type of threshold has been kind of
observed
in the past this is not a this is a
continuous threshold but the discrete
threshold so people have uh observed and
i think eugene lawler put it most
poetically
that
say there there seems to be like these
things where there is parameter often
the parameter is either two versus three
in a lot of problems
where the version of with two
of the problem like say matching sat etc
is easy but the version with three and
above becomes hard
and he uh
in the 1970s he already wondered what's
the reason behind this can we find an
explanation for that and maybe uh
uh
now we have like a little bit of better
insight than uh
than what we do and
you know what we knew in the 1970s
and like i mentioned the caveat is that
this is going to be a bird's-eye view or
like if you want to tweet-sized view
and
i hope the rest of the workshop and i
think already we've seen it with adam
stock will be an archives
eyes view like more going into the
details
and uh thanks to some hopkins who
commented on some previous versions of
this slide he mostly gave me a lot of uh
reference that i couldn't fit in so he
mostly
helped me being aware of what i'm
missing and i can also mention that i
should not receive special things yes
you also mentioned that you should not
receive sales respect but let me just
tell you yeah if there is
anything good about this talk
it's all me if anything is arrows et
cetera it's just sam's fault
okay
so like what's the general setup that we
are
interested in
so um
so so we have some kind of a function
say i'll call it j in this talk much
being n variables to one real number
and we can define lots of we can think
of this as the problem instance the
problem instance is a description of
this function j
and now we can define
all sorts of computational tasks and
generally the computational task we will
be interested will be something related
to minimizing j
so the search problem
is to find
an a minimizer of j so you want to find
x star that minimizes j over some set
think of the set as either say the
boolean cube or maybe the sphere that
would be the two sets we are interested
today but generally you can think of
any set
the sampling problem is to sample a
random minimizer sample x star that is a
uniform among all the set of minimizers
the counting problem is to compute how
many minimizers are there
and the refutation problem is to prove
that
the minimum is at least something that
write another way to prove that for
every x in s
j of x
is at least better
the decision or also known as hypothesis
testing problem is to distinguish you
have some alpha that is smaller than
better
and you want to distinguish between
those j's where the minimum is smaller
than alpha and those js where the
minimum is larger than beta
and the planted recovery is when we
design some j
to ensure that x star some fixed x star
that is planted is the minimizers and we
want to recover it
so we typically in this case
jxstar is designed so that x star
is the unique minimizer or any minimizer
is very close to x-star and now the goal
is to recover it
so these are the kind of tasks
we're interested in
and again any questions
and some examples of what j's we might
be interested in
include the following so for example if
you have a sat formula
j of psi could be the number of
constraints that so give it takes as
input an assignment and the output is
the number of constraints violated by x
so minimizing uh
minimizing j corresponds to finding uh
trying to find a satisfying assignment
or as as satisfying as possible
you can have a graph
and then j will count the number of
edges that are improperly colored by a
coloring so minimizing is basically
trying to find the coloring you can have
a set of equations
and then minimizing is like the you know
least square minimization or you can
have uh
trying to find the maximum
eigenvector or in a tensor to find the
vector that's most correlated with some
tensor or you can have like say you're
given a set of label data
and you're trying to find some x that is
the weights of some neural network and
you're trying to
minimize the errors of this neural
network
so all of those are examples of some js
that you would want to minimize
and uh
to find the minimizer or you know to not
know how many minimizers there are to
sample for minimizers etc etc etc
okay
and how does this relate to inference
the most kind of natural relations is
the following you have some kind of a
model
where
you have hidden parameters
and you have some observed data and this
is very much like what adam talked about
could be the
you know hidden parameters and
is some
w
and
and theta and the observed data is
samples from a distribution where uh
you know x1 xn that are sampled
according to a
you know the easing model or
write the w a
i j x i x j
j x j or something like that or you know
in any case you're trying to recover
some parameters
so uh the
natural
the natural j to define would be
that uh
say minus the log probability of uh
given the observed data minus the log
probability that a given x
is the hidden parameter so now basically
if you're doing uh trying to find the
minimizer corresponds to doing the
maximum upper posterior probability to
trying to find the x
and the x star that
maximizes the probability
you can also try to do posterior
sampling which corresponds to a sample
p star such that the probability of p
star is exponential in minus g of x
and more generally you can imagine that
you have some kind of a prior mu and you
want to sample and
p star where p star of x is proportional
to e to the minus j of x times the
power
and then
and then in such cases it's known that
there is this variational principle that
the p star
is the thing that um
is going to um generally pissed off it
will be the thing that kind of maximizes
that so that minimizes
the expected value of j according to
it's the among all p's the thing that
will maximize the expected value of j
and the distance in k divergence from
the prior
and this trading of this tau
so generally if you put the tower here
and this tau and
the reason we put out is the
if the if we're talking about the
uniform prior
and we want to sample uh here
proportional to minus tau inverse j then
basically the k divergence becomes just
the entropy
or minus the entropy
and we are in
and this is kind of this is known as a
temperature
right so this is like you can think of
you have a system
and you want on one hand to minimize
energy and on the other hand the hotter
the system which means
basically the bigger tau is you also
want to uh to have large entropy
and
and p star basically solves this
optimization problem
okay
so
and if you talk about general general
like generalization or just inference so
some any type of
say
learning problem you typically what
would have is you have like some j the
ideal j that you want to optimize which
is the loss
of uh whatever thing you're going to
output on the population and then the
thing you actually have access to is not
j but j hat which is the loss on a
sample
and the hope is that you'll minimize j
hat and you hope that
if j hat is small and
and then j's will also be small and i
say small prime and small double prime
because these two smallers might not be
the same
classically we generally want to have a
situation where the the difference
stands to zero
and
in modern setting typically we
often cannot hope for that but we we
hope that somehow
if you didn't do something stupid and if
you minimize j using natural algorithms
then you'd still have the case that if j
hat is smaller than j is also small
maybe not
in the sense of a vanishing gap but at
least
if one is smaller than the other is
small
and
and all of these kind of gen for us
also motivates this notion of trying to
look for approximation versions of all
of these things so rather than finding
the exact minimizers
maybe sometimes we just want to find
x that is small such as jx is smaller
than alpha rather than sampling exactly
from the minimizers maybe we want to
sample from this probability where the
you know the probability is proportional
to e to the minus tau inverse j so
when tau
is zero then this basically is the
minimizers
but when tau is non-zero then this is
somehow a soft version of that
instead of computing
the actual count you might compute
this partition function like the sum of
all of those things
and
you know maybe don't want to find x star
exactly but at least find something that
is nearby to it
so we'll also be interested mostly be
interested in these kind of softer
versions
okay
so now
let me say
uh kind of give some some intuition
what's going on in this typical picture
of these things so let's just imagine
that j
this energy function is like the number
of violated constraints in some
constraint satisfaction problem that has
n equations and delta n constraints
and
p star will be
you know proportional to e to the minus
j
with some you know relation some
temperature as
as the t goes to infinity as the
temperature goes to infinity let's say
that the temperature goes to zero
this becomes uh this basically
puts all of the weights on the absolute
minimizers when the temperature is not
zero then it puts the weight on some
things that are near minimizers
and the set of
and let's define say the s star of alpha
the set of x is that a j of x is less
than alpha
and generally there is going to be some
relation so
p star is basically you can think of it
as the uniform distribution
over esta of alpha for some alpha that
depends on tau
so generally the
the smaller tau is the bigger alpha is
and what often it looks like is the
following thing suppose we were to try
to plot
the entropy
of pista alpha
as a function
of
as a function
of these parameters pistol tower i
should have said but it doesn't matter p
star as a function of these things
as a function of delta
as a function of uh tau inverse or the
function of minus alpha
and the behavior is generally the same
so so generally for example if we think
of it as uniform over this set
then we can see that the smaller alpha
is or in some sense the bigger minus
alpha is the smaller this set so the
entropy decreases
similarly as you put more constraints it
becomes harder to minimize minimize
so and so so again like the entropy will
decrease
or um as you
decrease the enter the temperature or
increase tau inverse
then again the your min your uniform
over a smaller set so the entropy
decreases so in all of these cases it
doesn't matter what the x axis is
it's going to look something like that
as you
doesn't have to have exactly the shape
but it's going to be some monotone
function which eventually hits zero
eventually you have no entropy left
or maybe you're only focused on one
single x
and then
and as you increase the x the entropy
decreases
and the intuition that we have is the
following so in some regime
in some in some regime here
as
in the beginning
there are many many solutions
so this set is very big and it's also
easy to find
the search problem is easy
as we continue
if we continue kind of to the limit then
in some sense you know if minus alpha
for example is too big then solutions
simply don't exist
so you cannot find them because they're
simply not there
and in many many computational problems
there will be some intermediate vision
which we're trying to understand where
the solutions exist but we believe that
they are hard to find
and so so sometimes we would call it say
we would say this is the statistical
threshold and this is the computational
question maybe i should also do it on
for the
so sometimes we say okay this is the
statistical and this is the
computational threshold so and
so at some point solutions still exist
but they become hard to find and at some
point you push the parameter even
further and at some point they don't
exist anymore
and then there are like other types of
problems that i mentioned before uh
these planted or fusion problems
where suppose you continue this uh even
further
so for those problems for planted
problems we typically think of this
piece star
not at the set of solution but at the
set of spurious solutions so think of it
as the background noise
so
so you have some set of two solutions
and say if you add the planted solution
no matter how many how much you increase
say for example how much you increase uh
the number of constraints they always
this solution will always satisfy it so
these two solutions will kind of always
have some non-zero entropy or non minus
infinity entropy let's ignore this minor
things
and uh but but at some point the
spurious solutions will disappear
so what you can think of in these cases
is that there is a certain
threshold which is often known as a sat
threshold
where superior solutions don't exist
anymore
and before that in some sense at least
at least you hear it sometimes it
depends on the problem but definitely
when there is more superior solutions
than
than the real solutions then the problem
you cannot recover the planted signal
simply information theoretically you
could because the the noise overwhelms
the signal
so you simply cannot do that information
theoretically there there you can find
solutions you can find good things but
they will not be the planted thing that
you look for so even information
theoretically you simply cannot plan and
find the planted signal
as you can if you continue this
to the limit at some point the planted
sim signal will be so strong that will
just shout at you and say i'm here i'm
here find me so you'll be very easy to
recover the planted signal
but again there would be some
intermediate regime
where recovery is in principle possible
if you had exponential time
but it is computationally difficult
so that's kind of an intuition that we
have that there is some in in generally
when we're talking about these problems
for average case
then
this regime is the regime where we're
interested in the search problem
say sampling
problem or counting
and this is the easy part of this regime
and this is the hard part of this regime
and this regime is where we're
interested in the refutation problem say
to
if there was no planted thing to prove
that the recent one or the recovery of
the planted or inference we can also
think of it as a planted problem and
here this would be the hard regime and
this would be the easy region
so that's kind of the general picture
that we have some uh intuition and i'll
try to talk about what works
try to substantiate it and where do we
find these thresholds
but maybe this is a good point to
stop for questions
yes
so typically like typically the way we
think of planted problems is that there
is kind of a random part
and
a planted part
and and basically the start threshold is
when the random part doesn't contribute
anymore the random part is unsatisfiable
and the the only
satisfying thing that remains is the
thing that you planted
sometimes maybe what you've planted it
has like a little bit more than entropy
that that's one solution and then maybe
information theoretically you'll be will
be able to recover just a little bit
earlier
but at that point definitely you'll be
able to recover
so we're going to look at two different
types of problems one of them is
completely random problem where there is
no planted signal and you just have the
red curve
and another one is this planted problem
where there is this planted solutions
that kind of remain there
as you increase the parameter and then
there is this
this
random part that decreases and basically
you can think of the of the ratio
between the red and the blue as the
signal-to-noise ratio
to some extent
not exactly the rate of equal but
generally the parameter x kind of
controls
you can think of this parameter x
whatever is the x axis as the signal to
noise ratio
and the interesting thing is that yes
similarly all of those parameters kind
of behave quan qualitatively behaves
similarly you increase the number of
constraints you decrease the temperature
or you you know you increase the
you decrease the threshold where you
want to find a minimizer this kind of
behaves similarly
okay
this is generally the the picture and
what we're really trying to figure out
um maybe
one way to think about it
is
as a cartoon
basically
the cartoon the statistical physicists
mostly care about this line and maybe we
care about these lines where the
difference you know is in computer
scientists we care about the difference
when the problem becomes a
computationally hard and easy
but actually they care deeply about this
line as well as we'll see
and this thing i think they probably
should care but they don't really
exactly have the language to do so but
and
we'll see that
yes and at some point yeah it's not
clear how to place kind of modern
machine language machine learning
problems exactly in this framework we'll
talk about it at the very very end
i hope
so here is some very very basic
intuition so if you have an optimization
problem
uh
intuition is that if it looks like this
it's easy
if it looks like that it's hard
that's
right if you if you were to drop a
marble from the top it's pretty clear
that here you will find yourself in the
global minimum and here you'll find
yourself like playing pachenko right
so
so it's kind of um yeah
intuitively
easy that's something intuitively clear
that the landscape of solution
will change
at least for natural algorithms that
kind of progress along a solution
the right thing would be much harder
than the easy
much harder than the left scenario so in
general in this kind of
when the landscape looks like that you
you imagine that local algorithm will
get stuck at a very bad local minima and
random works will take a very long time
to converge because you know if you
started here
the your
chance of getting here will be very very
small
so now
let's try to make this kind of a little
bit more formal
so one of the ways to try to formalize
this notion of uh
one of the ways to try to formalize this
notion of um
what does it mean uh
to capture a measure that will capture
when you are in the left side and when
you're on the right side is this notion
of a overlap distribution
so suppose you have this measure p star
that basically is the uniform
distribution
among
everything that is say below a certain
threshold
so here the p star will just be on the
like this
thing here and here it will be based on
a lot of different
clusters so
so basically if you if you do the
histogram of the overlap distribution
you take two random elements from p star
and you look at say the normalized dot
product
man maybe i should do it like this with
absolute value so it really is between 0
and 1 doesn't matter that much
so and
so here you have basically a single
cluster so it'll kind of look something
like in in the easy case
it will basically have something like
that right so it's
it's the uniform distribution over here
and everything will be
you know most of this
it's in high dimension most of those
points will have some i don't know 80
overlap or whatever they are
so so it will be basically
something like that
and here
if you have some clusters and let's say
right now we're thinking that you have
some large number of clusters but not so
so large that the probability of being
in
in the same cluster is zero then you'll
have these two um
two different um modes
so
if you are in the same cluster then
you're close to each other if you're in
a different cluster then you're far from
each other so the overlap is small
and the
for people know statistical physics this
is kind of what's known as the static
say one replica symmetry breaking
so some intuition is that this overlap
distribution
um
this is the easy case and this is the
hard case
and and we'll now
soon talk about some works that make it
more formal
and a lot of this work is by
david who's sitting here
so let's let's
get into a little bit more and this is
this figure from uh
is the bova and cascala
so
think of for example some a planted
problem so so
say
say a random problem the entropy would
be on the red a planted problem the
entropy would be
this purple which kind of corresponds to
both the random solution and the planted
solution and they looked at the coloring
problem but
and the x-axis here is average degree
but it really is
very generic the picture that we see
so in the beginning
we basically have all solutions are in a
single cluster
and in that
cluster one of them is the planted
solution
so this is this kind of
this kind of picture so this is the case
that this is easy for the search problem
this is very hard to recover the planted
solution because it's just one among
many but it's easy for the
search problem
then as you proceed
the formula the landscape undergoes what
they call as a shuttering
but basically it becomes
this type of thing
where initially there are exponentially
many clusters
and the plan the planted one is one of
them and then
later there are only a
small number of clusters maybe at some
point even a constant and the planted
one remains because it's planted
and
this would be the case
where the
search problem is hard
but uh once the planted is bigger than
once the entropy of the planted kind of
dominates the the plant of the cluster
dominates everything else then recovery
at least is possible
in information theoretically
and at some point when you increase in
this case it undergoes kind of a
discontinuous
jump
and and now uh if there was no planted
distribution there would be nothing left
there would be a
this is the saturn sat threshold for
random for a for random
instance of the csp
and now there is nothing left
but in the planted thing it will still
be hard to recover
and then so recovery or
of a planted signal or refutation
certifying that there is no
there is no uh
solution would still be computationally
hard until we reach
some larger
area where we can refute and can recover
the signal
so that would be kind of the intuition
and yeah and this is called the
so this is called when the exponentially
many clusters you call it dynamic uh
replica symmetry breaking when there is
only a constant number you call
static but let's not go into the
difference between those two and
basically the idea is that this in this
overlap
basically we think of the overlap
as in the hard phase as the reason the
the overlap distribution has this
gap
where there is a
certain overlap that simply do not
appear
and we'll see how this relates to
hardness soon
so now
so now i want to just review the the
basic tasks that we're talking about in
the algorithms and then focus on a
particular and
then focus on particular uh case which
is this
um p spin and or a px or constraint
satisfaction problems
maybe i don't know maybe before that
again like
i mean right now we're still i still
haven't done much maps so maybe it's
still too vague to ask about but still
feel free i mean anything
any questions comments etc
yes
do you have any intuition indeed i think
it's the case that physicists
focus much less on the certification
problem than other problems yes do you
have any any question why is that
problem less physical more computer
scientistic than the other problems yeah
i mean one of the issues is that
if we uh go back to uh this
then notice that i didn't have a drawing
here because there is really no
landscape of solution to talk about
right the physicists the planted one is
kind of
something new that uh
most physicists don't know about only
these guys know
and uh and the random one doesn't really
make sense beyond the fat threshold the
there is no solution there there is no
solution so there is no landscape of
solutions
so it's very hard to say for example for
a random
3xo what's the difference between
a random 3xo with 100n constraints or
end to the 1.5
constraints because both of them have no
solutions so in terms of solution
landscape they look the same but in
terms of computational they look
differently so i think they you really
need a different language
somehow it's clear to me that there
should be universal way to look at all
of the regimes the similarities we and
we are do use similar algorithms in all
of those but uh
but the way when you focus on landscape
the
once you be of the sat threshold
everything looks the same and looks
trivial
so i think that's the the challenge
yes
i think it's related but also i think to
wrap my head around how to think about
the distinction between
the green and the one the the
computationally hard and convenient easy
to refute in terms of the overlapped uh
distribution because with the thing it
seems
that uh
pink i don't know what to do yeah
right the overlap distribution would be
nice yeah so overlap i think doesn't
really make sense beyond this sat
threshold
so basically this is uh maybe a marquee
so this is the case where you ask this
is this is the case where that you are
in the search setting
and here you can talk about overlap to
help you determine so overlap can help
you determine this line
once you are here
this is the
refutation setting
or planted recovery
and here we don't really know
here we need something else
so the situation that the solution jumps
at you
does not you can't see that through the
overlapping yes no no no because because
the the random part the the overlap
distribution is kind of the distribution
of solutions to the random part and the
random part is flat
from this point on so for this point on
there are simply no solutions
so you need somehow something else and
and and we will talk about a little bit
about what is something else is uh later
yes
um
i mean you could think of it as also
temperature parameters temperature
priority will still be a very similar so
if instead of average degree will degree
decrease there and you will
decrease the temperature you will still
have something very similar
where uh you know at some
you know at some point it might not be
completely flatlining but i don't think
the the
for example in some of these problems
the
the point in which refutation becomes
easy
is way beyond anything statistical
physicists care about because uh
for example in three exo the refutation
threshold is n to the 1.5
and and the whole business with
statistical physics is about constant
times n like the like millionaire like a
once things are like million n or you
know or into the 1.1 any finite
temperature will kind of not make a
difference
so somehow
you know i don't think solution
landscape will tell you where to find
this line
maybe it will be more clear later
maybe it will take the weeks or more i
mean i think part of this
yes
also i think
yeah
because what is a refutation yes it
depends on what it outputs in all the
other instances
well but you could pick a planted
recovery but and it does seem like you
eventually like
it so that saying there's a reputation
algorithm somewhat like a different
problem than uh but
but but in some sense the it's very
striking that you can use
it doesn't seem like you use similar
methods like you know linear programs
etc you could use rebounding algorithms
to try to solve the problems here and
you could use with uh
you know refutation to try to solve this
and the planted thing does seem very
very similar like
we have in the planted in some sense
it's the search problem but somehow it
behaves very very differently so
so it's um it's a little bit less
yeah it's a little bit less clear what's
going on but uh
okay but in any case our intuition is
that
at least in this regime where we are
below the uh
at least in this regime
where the overlap tells us when things
are easy and when things are hard
so now let's just try to kind of do a
catalog of
algorithms and tasks
and i'll just say that you know i'll
i'll try to put arrows between
algorithms and tasks but the truth is i
didn't spend a lot of time on it and you
might you know might not agree with me
on all of those
um
arrows and and part of the reason is
because
eventually like you can use a lot of
these algorithms for a lot of those
tasks at least
so maybe there should be even more
arrows so generally local search or
gradient descent
very natural algorithms you can use to
find the search problem to minimize
things
belief propagation you can also try or
approximate message passing also amp you
also want to use for the search problem
sampling
classical thing to do
monte carlo markov chain
counting you can use uh the monte carlo
market will change i think also from the
messages of belief propagation you get
some kind of
approximation of marginals of counting
refutation is really where you know uh
convex programs naturally work for
refutation but you can use them with
rounding algorithms to solve the search
problem
and probably there are ways by the way
there are usually ways if you can do the
search problems sometimes you can also
try to do the sampling problem for
example you know
maximize also on uh on some random
direction and output that and maybe that
will give you sampling etc
the decision you could use sos and but
you can also everything that uses
decision is easier than search so
everything that you could use
that search could also be used for
decision
and
there has been this framework
a low degree likelihood that also is
useful for decision often it's useful to
show that decision is hard
and and
in planted recovery you can also try to
use these low degree things and
also
there is statistical query model i think
the natural thing is to try to use that
to show that
planted recovery is hard but you can
also try to apply this framework for
other problems as well
so some of those are algorithms that
people use some of those are models that
people
use to rule out algorithms
generally
the main point i want to convey is that
they're like these all this collection
of natural algorithms and they all seem
to get
similar even though they seem maybe
superficially different they all seem to
get stuck at the same points typically
the focus here
of this um
in the next thing i'm going to talk
focus on a p spin or px or it depends on
whether you're a physicist or computer
scientist what you call it
a problem so
so now i'm going to look at specific j
so what is the p spin
case
p spin a
function that you objective
then say if p equals two you're trying
to minimize
you're given j which is some
coefficients some matrix
and by n matrix you're trying to
minimize j i j x i x j
and if i was adam clivens i may have
would have added some
one
some some coefficient some linear
coefficient for the exercise like he did
in his talk but
i'm too lazy
so i'll just like use just pure thing
jij
and if p equals three then it's j i j k
so you're given some tensor you're
trying to
minimize find the x i's that minimize
correlation with this tensor
and uh again if i was not lazy i would
write for you also what it looks like
when it's p equals four five etcetera in
general p is basically
j of x
you can think of it as
dot products of j and x tensor p so you
can think of j as some tensor
and and
for this problem then typically we think
of the two cases where most
the case that's natural for us as
computer scientists is to say if you
think of a random instance
that a jij j the coefficients are
either zero or plus minus one and most
of the time they are zeros and we choose
the probability that they are plus minus
one
so that there will be delta n
uh delta n on zero coefficients in
expectation so that's kind of the number
of constraints
and so that would be like say a 3x or if
we choose this and we have this then
basically well
each each of one of those is basically
like a three xo equation
if the xi's are plus minus one
then this is like a free xor equation
where uh you know you you get uh if
we're trying to minimize it then you
know when
depending on whether this is plus or
minus it's whether we want deploy the
product of those things to be minus one
or plus one or similarly
if you thought of them of the over gf2
whether they want the xo to be
a one or zero
and sometimes we also think of those as
normal
with some standard deviation
and generally we can also think of the
x's as being either they say the sphere
or a plus minus one
so when two
if your maximizing minimizing over the
sphere then this is basically
a 2xo this is strongly related to
maximum cut
and also sharing tonkyo patrick models
so all of those basically different
names for
this problem of uh minimizing uh
this one uh when even for random j and
where over the over the boolean cube
uh
if you're just minimizing over the
sphere then if j is just a matrix in p
equals two they're just you just trying
to find the minimum eigenvalue
which is something we obviously know how
to do
when uh
so in the case of the two there is a
difference although we'll see maybe the
difference is not as big because in the
random case
maybe this is obviously easy but this
tends to be also easy just less
obviously so
in the three and above case then
this is a cake sore and this is
basically tensor maximization both of
them are
you know just switch the sign minus j or
j and this is a or injective tenses no
norms sometimes known it's also useful
in quantum information still etc
and generally
as we'll see this side is easy this size
is hard
as a
in that quote by a
eugene and lola
and
maybe uh this would be a good place to
take the break it's a little bit earlier
but is that okay
yes
so maybe just maybe if there is any
question about it so we'll try to talk
about some evidence on where things
become hard and easy
um for in this problem
so why for example the three and above
is hard and the two is easy
question
of yes two and three
what you could consider a mixture of the
two-spin and three-spin we will
we will consider because actually that's
easier for me uh
i mean there is a very a complex paper
of montanari that shows that the sk
model random sk model
is solvable in polynomial time and
you know with the po2 but
it's actually much easier
to consider the mixture and then move
but move to the sphere case
where there is an easier picture of a
predecessor paper of subug and that's
where actually the result we'll talk
about
okay so we'll take a break perfect yeah
so we'll be back here exactly 20 minutes
3 15.